Hello and welcome to the Active
Inference Lab.
Today is April 14th, 2021
and we're here in guest stream
number 4.1 with Elliot Murphy.
So this is going to be
a really interesting talk.
And Elliot, we appreciate you coming on.
So I'll just pass it to you
to introduce yourself,
introduce the topic,
and then share some slides.
So anyone who's watching life
or I guess later in the comments,
just ask questions and we'll have time
during this presentation and at the end
to go over some comments.
But thanks again, Elliot,
and looking forward to hearing this.
Awesome. Yeah. Thank you very much.
So I am a post-doc working at U.S.
Health in Houston, Texas.
I work on intracranial recordings
of lot of patients
doing a lot of language tests, trying
to explore the neural basis of language.
And today
I am going to present some slides,
kind of reviewing a recent preprint
that is currently in review
on active inference for energy principle.
And I was very.
Yep. Looks good.
Okay.
So I'm going to give you a month
to look into the topic
and then talk a bit about linguistics
and then try and wrap up.
We'll make this more of a conversation.
Comments, questions,
objections, obviously.
Anyway, so yeah, like I said,
this is the preprint
that's currently in review
with Eamonn Holmes.
I call for something useful.
The argument is that natural language
syntax complies
in some degree with friendship principle,
so just outlining some kind of
really cool and
basic principles.
I want to make this conversation
a little bit more philosophical
than than than normal.
And obviously,
this is this lab is the business lab.
So I want to introduce some linguistics
topics more than the topics,
because the audience might be less
familiar with syntactic theory.
So to begin with, natural language
syntax yields
what linguists then call unbounded array
of hierarchically structured expressions
when bounded, meaning
that they can potentially go on forever.
There's no upper bound
on the limit of a sentence, right?
You can always make any sentence longer
by simply adding.
John said that I'm beginning of it
and it gets longer.
The only thing that stops sentences
going off forever is the working memory
the age of the average human
being in the age of the universe.
No sense of constant
private interest at some point.
And what the genetic component
in principle could do that,
but also the language,
the fact that you could in principle
generate unbounded array of expressions.
So I kind of argued in this paper
that these are used
in the service of active inference,
which is intent in accord
with the principle for the general goal.
That's the kind of alliance and consent
that works with those
of the normative model for organic system
behavior associated with the ATP.
So I'm going
to be relying on theoretical linguistics
with special emphasis on syntax,
which is the system
that determines
the kind of order that will go in the
structure and organization in relation
to the organizational relations
between words and sentences.
So a lot of these design
principles are kind of
general
to the biological components of language,
not just for specific
instantiation of language.
And so they're not specific
to English or French or Swahili,
that kind of general design principles
about how the language system
seems to be organized.
So I can say that I want to emphasize
emphasize more on the linguistics,
something more than a reference,
just that to the exposition.
And although the preprint itself has
all the relevant details, it really more.
But yeah, but kind of the brief
historical background here
is that since around the 10th century,
about 20, 25 years ago,
linguists have basically been developing
theories of linguistic computation
which invoke economy principles.
So basically the idea is that
when you pass and construct a sentence,
there are signs and computations
that enter into that process.
It's not just a single kind of chunk,
but you memorize what produce you do
in discrete operations.
And yet, for some reason, there's
currently no means of grounding
or motivating these ideas
through more general linguistic domains.
So recently,
proposed principles of economy,
such as minimum search or
least ever criteria, which I'll explain.
I'll give you definitions obsolete.
And I argue
that they adhere to the epithet.
And if this can be shown,
then this permits a greater degree
of explanatory power to the FFA
with respect to highlight which functions
and it also presents
linguistic perspective,
a grounding of notions
between people building and so on.
So in other words, that the idea is this
natural language syntax is a system,
it's an organic system,
it's a formal system.
Maybe it can be described
using the language of
theory, of recursive functions
and capability
imported from computer science
and all the rest of it.
But there's a problem.
And all of these principles of economy
and language design
in the literature are unsurprisingly kind
of language focused, right?
That have a very kind
of linguistically encoded background.
And so there's been a paradox
because one of the original goals of this
program was actually to say, okay, let's
see how much of language is actually
that can arise
through the kinds of formal principles
that given
the organizing shape of snowflakes
or the morphology of lightning bolts,
so on kind of just general
domain, general laws of nature
that can give rise in different ways
across different domains.
And yet the linguistic languages
are still kind of
encoding these in language specific
things, rather than relating them
to more general principles of brain
organization or mental computation.
So that's the kind of background
and so
many historical insights into syntax,
I argue, are kind of consistent
with the FPP,
which provides another perspective on
to which the principles
governing syntax are not limited to,
on which they actually reflect.
The main general processes
that underpin a variety of computations
is also consistent with a strain
within theoretical linguistics
that explores how syntactic computation
may adhere to general principles
that may well fall
within the biological natural law,
in particular
considerations of minimal confusion,
such that certain linguistic
theories might be engaging with
general properties of organic systems,
but in fact, languages are.
So I think that's kind
of a beautiful idea there, that
all the other languages
that we speak English, French, German,
but only are they biologically grounded.
But actually the rules
that kind of govern the what you can say,
what you can't say, and indeed
how you and your brain computes
some parts or sentences
as part of that process.
You kind of get
for free if you just assume
extra biological,
natural law, one of which you can
you can argue is is the French principle.
So that's the kind of background it.
So the structuring elements of FP
can be detected in language.
And I'm not only I've argued recently
at the complex level
caucus and his colleagues
of what was a bunch of papers
in the last year
or two, mainly in 2020, arguing that
active inference can relate to narrative
comprehension, interpersonal dialog,
like when two people talk
and cooperative intentional communication
and speech segmentation.
And I'm going to kind of argue that
all of these things rely on something
much more lower down.
And that syntax,
if you can't
syntactically construct the phrase,
if you can't put two and two together
and form a phrase,
you're not going to get very far.
You at least need to do that
in order to engage in, you know,
intentional operation and narrative and
and storytelling and speech segmentation.
You at least need to be able
to form a phrase, right?
If you can't do that, you can't do
anything to do with language.
So I'm kind of arguing that, you know,
all of the all of the ways that the FP
can be related to all of these things
here is arising from a kind of
fundamental lower level consideration
to do with the way that
phrasebook computations are executed.
Elliot.
Have you changed any slides?
We can't see any slides changing just.
Okay.
Yeah, I have a few slides.
Just maybe unshared reshare.
But it stands alone
what you've said as well.
But it will be also good
to have the visual. See?
Okay, how about this?
So we see your mouse and then
just advanced like on the left bar.
Like, click on to your next slide.
Mm hmm. Yep.
Perfect. Okay.
What about now?
No. Okay.
Oh, I see.
Okay.
Well, I might have to the.
Like, window in focus.
Yeah.
This, just as a non
linguist was really interesting
that you appeal to, like,
kind of bigger laws then linguistics.
Mm hmm.
Like complex systems theory or snowflakes
and lightning's, like you said.
And then just pointing out
that you're kind of
bringing linguistic level rules
or patterns into a bigger scope.
Okay, cool.
So we see it with Chomsky now.
Okay.
Well, I've only skipped,
like five slides,
so everything that I've just said is
so I show the paper,
here's the paper,
I simply regurgitate this.
I like this.
All of these things already read out.
So, yeah,
if you had what I said, then that's good.
Great.
Okay. So can you see slide number eight?
Yep. Cool. Awesome. Okay.
Okay. Okay.
So if the process of constructing
hierarchically organized sets
of linguistic features
and the way to phrase incentive
can be shown to adhere
to principles of efficient reputation,
then this process must also operate
within fundamental constraints
on your organics,
which is those applied by the FFA,
in which the homeostatic brain minimizes
the dispersion of interest
figure it's ever been.
Can also allow us to understand
how natural language
complies with the constraints
imposed on worldly interactions,
deriving same features of language.
So again, at the moment
this is all pretty abstract.
I'm going to give you some much more
like concrete examples, so I apologize.
It's a little bit
philosophical at the moment
and so a number of robust findings
from theoretical acoustics
can be used to support
the image of the brain
as a constructive organ, assembling
and inferring linguistic representations
in the sense of surprise, minimization
and related goals.
So syntactic structures are not mind
external entities.
They're not the kind of thing
that physicists could easily examine,
but they're rather actively
interpreted by the brain
as seemingly, with the help of endogenous
low frequency activity,
coordinating cross cortical gamut
optimization of linguistic features
according to what your recent models,
which I'm gonna get back to at the end.
So in other words,
we have a general framework
for how to implement the abstract level,
and we also maybe have a kind of
at least understanding
about what's implemented in the brain.
That's the kind of the long vision
of this presentation.
At the end, we're going to try
and wrap it up by returning to the brain.
But for now, I'll
give you a more kind of concrete example.
So I said that syntactic structures
have to be different.
The reform of inference,
their inference generation,
they're not just passive perception.
So if you have a structure like
we watched a movie with Jim Carrey,
I can mean two things and it cannot.
I mean, the movie stars Jim Carrey,
The Truman Show episode.
We watched The Truman Show
or you actually watched the movie whilst
sat next to Jim Carrey.
It depends on how you pass it, right?
It depends on how which phrases get
merged with in which order, basically.
So there's a kind of general
schematic here, but you can have a fun
little operation up
in the pre-print paper that I mentioned.
But the basic idea is that this
structural ambiguity arises from syntax.
So therefore the whole process of syntax
has to be an inference process.
It's not given to us on a
we have to kind of
we have to do some homework in order
to construct every possible pass.
So that poses the problem.
How does it do?
It is an inferential process.
So what are the
operations involved in that?
So here's a kind of a standard.
What local structure in the West is,
is that there's two different ways
of passing the sentence.
You can have a shoot,
an elephant is wearing your pajamas,
which is definitely possible.
Or you can shoot out and walk away
and drop jump.
And it depends how you in
which order you merge the phrases right
in which which hierarchical relationship
is exhibited, if that makes sense.
So there's kind of a lot
of theoretical background here
and that I won't go into because that's a
whole different lecture.
But the basic idea is that there's
a ambiguity that instructs generation.
It's not always language,
as long as it's not beads on a string,
it's a it's a structure.
So along with that kind of theme,
I'm also assuming
a distinction in linguistics between
what's called AI language and E language.
And this is the really Christmas
emotions get clear.
So I want to make sure
this does make sense to everybody.
So an AI language is
the actual internal knowledge,
but an individual human being
has in their mind brain.
AI stands for individual internal
unintentional intentional with an s
meaning
meaning meaning separated meanings.
On the other hand,
you have Michael big language perspective
and that is actually arguably
not really a formula or coherent
is the idea
that language is a kind of external,
a system,
a mind external, an extra mental system
like the English language
is somehow out there in the world.
And when we learn the English language,
we kind of approximate
some kind of mind external system.
And we all have something in common.
We all approximate to
the English language in different ways,
but the island, which means that
when we actually communicate
with each other
and the reason why we can't successfully
communicate is not because we share e
language in common is because I languages
successfully and sufficiently overlap
to the degree
that we can actually communicate.
And so everybody's islands are different.
It's often said that there's
7000 languages on the bottom,
but that's actually not not true.
There's actually how many people
there are common, but it's like 7 billion
or something or half.
And that's how many languages there are.
Every human being
has a different language faculty set.
The parameters are set differently.
We all have different intellects,
different understandings and so on.
And that kind of sounds
really obvious, right?
When you think about it,
it's like obviously that's true.
But and B implications for the study of
language are actually pretty
full.
In other words, when we study linguistic
competence, we are studying like a mind
internal computational system
and we're not studying something outside.
So the English language is not something
that linguists actually study.
We don't know.
That's not a coherent concept.
It's like the concept of culture
or community or whatever.
It's these are not things
that physicists could identify.
And that's not to say
that we can't say things about them.
We can't obstruct the human mind,
construct theories of of e languages.
I guess
you can talk about the English language
you're changing over the decades,
which is kind of every coherent way
to talk about language,
and you can put it in that way.
Both are naturalistic perspective
from a biological perspective,
but the only way you can study
it is based on
what individual libraries do.
So to
give an example
here, and if you take a recent film,
I generally screen for yesterday
Hitman's wife's bodyguard
and the defining property of language is
said to be this unbounded
array of hierarchical,
organized expressions made recursion.
So recursion is a defining property
of natural language syntax.
But it turns out to be distributed
unevenly across the world.
So some people argue that saying
we just don't exhibit advocation at all.
And but this actually tells us nothing
about the actual biological language
of the word speakers of these languages
than Portuguese.
Right.
So the idea is that language
can easily, unavoidably
be exhibited by most of the world's
languages.
Again, when I say languages,
I mean a kind of convenient
description
of every individual's fixed language.
Probably the most Germanic languages only
allow a single criminal Johnson limited
to pronounce the German doesn't allow
it requires a bit in the possessive.
But in German you can say John's house,
you can't say John's sister's
friend's house.
So the above movie,
when it's released in Germany,
it's going to have to be called something
like The Bodyguard and Man's Wife,
which
has a slightly different tone on it.
But the idea is that this fundamental
capacity of language to execute recursion
and you can find all the ways
you can find it in a phrase embedding
and but phrases the way that we actually
for phrases or you can find it
in other ways like in this example here.
So relating us back to the MVP,
while the MVP is a very full principle
of least action,
such as those
that describe systems of consequence,
these are relatively recent programing.
Linguistics has suggested
that natural language, in fact,
it is the principle of principles
of least action.
I'm going to say
the modern
theoretical linguistics remains
comparatively remote
for the field in science,
but certain parts of it from this field
resonate with the mother of
so many biological and cognitive
principles of efficiency
might be special cases of a variational
principle of energy sharing.
This assessment should allow researchers
from distinct disciplines to reevaluate
their hypotheses and empirical evidence
in terms of low level graduate,
which is the kind of go
I have in mind here.
What we should also stress
as a recent paper does, but
it can be used as a methodological
heuristic for research
and but it's not a theory of everything,
it's just a fragment.
And actually,
I find this very similar to a framework
in linguistics
called the Minimalist Program,
which is a program
it's not a coherent yet, at least
it has a couple of theories,
working theories,
but it's not a coherent body of Dr.
Klein's ongoing research program
with a particular ideology and framework.
And that's exactly what the apathy is,
right?
It's a formal principle
which feels that I can contribute
to a discrete individual and separate.
And so theories depending
on what domain you're looking at.
And so I kind of like the idea
that both programmatic motions
and you can implement them a bit ways so
that so
we're working here with the ethics
and the people in question
doesn't work on ethics
so much it's not an applied approach.
The debate and so everything
has been argued to be more of a kind of
conceptual mathematical model
for self-organized systems.
And as a recent review
by Andreas makes clear,
there's number of ways
that they would be perceived
as an aid to scientific work
without constituting, like,
falsifiable statements
about the state of nature.
It's a it's program.
It's a way of usefully describing certain
jokes of nature
without necessarily covering them.
So while we argue
about natural language syntax
and so when we argue
that natural language syntax complies
with the French principle,
I'm not necessarily implying that the ATP
necessarily bars specific direct
predictions of that behavior.
It's rather a way of motivating
the construction of neural conceptual
arguments for how some practical systems
might be seen as realizing the goals of
others and
repeating the language, language
distinction, and focusing on knowledge
which is internal
to the mind of the Speaker,
exploring their apparent competence
rather than what they happen to produce.
So one example of what you can
think of immediately
is the existence of syntactic structures.
You contribute to a unique form
of some encouraging through maximizing
moral evidence and minimizing surprise.
I'm very in the actual paper in question.
I'm I'm
so I think it goes into more detail.
But the basic idea is that the highly
restricted set of syntactic projections,
what I call
the way that you can categorize a phrase,
nouns and bits
and components as a phrase
and so on, but restricted set
and finite set of ways
that you can define a particular phrase
as being a better phrase
or not phrase and achieve goal.
So you can also assume that languages and
languages that you're in comprehension
select the phrase structure.
That's least surprising
from the perspective
the hierarchical counter model.
Again, this goes back to the we watched
the movie with Jim Carrey example.
It's a prediction.
There's a pretty big rocket.
So as such, brain structure
building can be capsule internal action.
It's an actual internal action
that an individual does
in the sense of their commitment
framework
that selects among competing
hypotheses, i.e.
syntactic structures.
You can pass it this way,
you can pass it another way.
And also the same goes
for lexical semantics syntax them.
In other words, you can interpret
an individual with one word.
I'm going to give you
some examples with it.
So pretty much all of language
from individual words to sentences and
inferences
and also a little side
point here and writing
more directly to existing work
on active inference and communication.
And it's I think it's pretty interesting
that the recursive combinatorial
approaches of syntax has been argued
to facilitate recursive theory of mind.
Right.
So the ability, your ability
to know that someone else knows, that
she knows that you know this and so on
and it could be seen therefore
as deriving or piggybacking in some way,
and could space properties of either
linguistic communication,
which in turn serves
to unveil the head states
that other people's mental states,
which are the kind of standard assumption
and theory of mind, active inference
research, but I think can be related
much more directly to the language once
we understand that the extended kind of
use of theory of mind in language is it
comes directly from this as a property,
right?
Okay.
So I mean, I want to move on
to kind of the more concrete examples.
Everything I've said so far is
pretty philosophical and pretty abstract.
What I want to kind of give you
some actual concrete examples
so it makes more sense.
So it provides
additional constraints on what of system
can be physically realized.
That is very useful.
So take the first three principles
in classical recursive
function theory,
which are functions to propose
substitution, primitive recursion
and minimization.
These are all designed in a way
that you might think of
as computationally efficient.
They reuse
the output of various computations.
So for instance, substitution
replaces the argument of functions,
but no function.
Primitive recursion
defines a new function on the basis
of as opposed to it.
So bottoming out in a previously defined
function and minimization produces
the output of a function
with the smallest number of steps.
So the notion of minimizing surprise
can be used to ground observations
from theoretical physics
pertaining to the ground.
Its propensity to reduce the search space
during syntactic derivations
limit no tempering of objects
during static derivations,
so it restricts the number of resources
able to be confined in a given moment.
So in other words,
this is very kind of an abstract example,
but I'm going to give you
some more concrete ones in
during any particular parts of a sense,
you don't just search the next
on an instruction unit
just because you can't.
You only do so if you need to.
If the current number of lexical items
that you've already said.
So that's one thought and suffice
to generate a given interpretation,
then you don't need to
search for more items.
That's sufficient. Write down of words.
Don't just don't do more search
well message as possible.
And also relates
to the grammars propensity to limit
the range of reputation
resources able to be called upon
during any given stage of comprehension.
So examining
some core principles of occasion
natural language
clearly exhibits minimization, right?
While finally branching of structures
limits redundant computation.
The binary branching goes back to
that slide I showed a few minutes ago.
We have these binary branching
prescriptions, so I show an elephant
and my pajamas and that all relates
to that back a little bit.
Drive through successive implementations
of a binary branching operation
that simply puts two things together
and gives us an identity.
So natural language syntax
also exhibits discrete units.
Obviously this individual which
which leads to a discrete discontinuity
duality.
So syntax is driven
by closeness of computation.
So objects X and Y form a distinct object
to one.
Its objects
are also bounded to the other.
The fixed list so is bound by adjectives,
adverbs, prepositions, traumatizes,
tense objects, little nouns, a little bit
of spectral elements and so on.
Always have a peculiar, functional
and content related notions.
The hierarchical ordering is based on
a specific functional sequence as well,
and which imposes
direct restrictions of combinatorics.
These objects can be combined
into cycles, so recursive embedding
which can be extended
to non-local dependencies.
So an example of that is you have
flight number four output market.
So you can say the keys to the old wooden
cabinet are on the table
and not the keys to the old wooden
cabinet is on the table, obviously,
is those of keys
they have to mark, but they have to agree
and the number pictured.
Right.
So that's the example
where you have a non-local
and dependency between two elements.
So if to hold it in memory,
even though they cross
phrase boundaries, so syntax
still keeps on generating new structures,
but you have to associate one element
with a new element further boundary.
And so these properties are retained,
guarded by principles of minimal
search on links that
show in a minute,
fulfilling the goal of active inference
to construct meaningful representations
as efficiently as possible.
I think that's really
what it comes down to.
That's the kind of core crucial message
here.
If it can be shown that
the language system
constructs meaningful representations
as efficiently as possible,
then therefore
it must be absolutely everything.
And again, that contributes
to surprise minimization.
How much of the goals
so from the perspective of APB
and the range of possible structures
available to comprehend is provide
alternative promises, but generalize
such preclude overfitting sensory data.
So the complexity of linguistic stimuli
can be efficiently map to a small series
of regular and regularized in the sense
of when syntactic formats.
This contributes to the brain's
more general goal
of restricting itself to a limited number
of characteristic states.
So therefore it's only changeable things
if you have to write by mapping
syntactic structures the language
extent of conceptual interfaces.
Now that's a kind of a key to language
external interfaces.
What that means is you have a narrow
and a component of language,
the kind of narrow school,
the narrow faculty of language,
but we can call it whatever you like.
It's just the capacity to
to construct the structures.
But then you have a language external,
mental modules and memory systems
and what have you,
attentional control systems
in the mind that are located across
different cortical surfaces.
It's kind of the standard, the standard
much of the framework, I guess.
And so by mapping these structures,
general language through these language,
external interfaces
in a manner adherent
to principles of common
language can be seen as engaging
in a series of questions and
answers which sensory data
specific.
So those that work in theoretical
semantics assumes that there are
and there are flexible concepts
that language can interface with.
And there also nonfunctional concepts
don't have words
that there are systems, that
there are properties of human thought.
But the language system
seems pretty clear
and it likes to use explicit.
But there are other modules of cognition
that for some reason can't be
linguistically encoded as easily.
That's kind of a weird property, right?
But why should we able
why should we be able to linguistically
encode and communicate about,
send thoughts going to others?
And so one example is many of the world's
languages.
Again, when I say will as languages,
I mean in quotation marks.
And what I really mean, this
many of the individual human beings,
they make use of
quantification of numeracy, often
typically seen as this
from the parietal patient,
which is interestingly closely linked
to major language sites.
So that might be one of the reasons
why it makes use of the
and so they make little use of it
despite featuring just as prominently
an ordinary experience.
Right?
Sensorium is filled with colors and
and this might be due to the randomness
of occipital visual regions of the brain.
Maybe, maybe not.
And that's one explanation.
Maybe it's wrong,
but it's one possible reason.
So, for instance, one might imagine
some functional, morphing,
encoding brightness
or shade of coloration in language.
You can imagine it.
Like if you were to invent
a new language, you could
you could encode color features,
some kind of inflection.
But it doesn't seem
to be the case, even though
color is a pretty good enough.
At same time, language seems to make
considerable use of certain quantum
book concepts like intentionality,
but not all this word.
If you're like no morphemes.
Mark how concerned
somebody is about something?
I'm very concerned about,
a little bit concerned that
which seems to be making
potentially neurally efficient use
of specific access, easily accessible
representational resources,
rather than less easily accessible
cognitive modules.
Write to map complex
meaning onto natural expressions.
So it's fair to observe that language
acts as an artificial context,
which helps constrain
what representations are recruited
and what impact
they have on reasoning and inference.
So words themselves are highly flexible
and metabolically cheap sources of price
throughout the neural hierarchy.
This is a really cool
idea that I'm going to expand
upon.
So to give you some
more examples of again,
right in this fact the active inference
and take the second ball, second
will go to the left of large box.
That's a pretty simple spatial direction,
but it can only be encoded
with natural language syntax.
You need that kind of
we organized infrastructure
to generate that particular thought.
Three simple, very simple direction.
But you can only generate inferences
about it through using the recursive
and or third approaches language.
Similarly, you have structures
like the young, happy, eager,
either going to talk to a Cambridge
pleasant man.
This involves unbounded, unstructured
coordination involving disjunction too.
So the distinction is X or Y,
which is a highly complex structure
to compete with a highly complex
conceptual structure.
And yet language users can easily
inherit ferret.
But it also opens the door
for a whole new species of inferences
to be generated.
New thoughts about the world,
new possible hidden states,
new things that you can think about.
And one of the examples, a luxury photo
of the space that it is. And
he says,
if you take a a pen on a piece of paper,
you can easily draw a man.
You can use it for a zebra.
But it's kind of difficult to draw
the thought that there is not
a zebra next to you right.
So if you try and conceptualize
the thought,
there is not a zipper right next to me,
how can you draw?
I need to take the fact
that there is no zebra next to me.
That's kind of weird. It's
kind of difficult to do.
I suppose you could draw like a man
and then a zebra and a line
through the zebra,
but that's kind of weird,
but still presupposes
that there's a zebra next to you
and so language generates
a whole new species
of a new form of thought, basically
generates a new format for thought,
which seems to be unique.
In other words,
not readily translatable into other
domains like visual representations
or so.
These rapid inferences of our properties
and states
in states can be generated
relatively effortlessly by language.
And like I said,
no other computational system in human
cognition that it can achieve this.
Well, that's the idea.
So a number of
economy principles have been proposed
in theoretical linguistics.
These were very powerful, in fact,
very good notions.
So Robyn explained to many of them,
but I will give some examples
and these are open framed.
Like in the beginning
they've all been framed exclusively
within a linguistic context,
invoking highly domain specific notions,
despite a part of the intended
project of modern theoretical acoustics
being to embed linguistic theory within
principles, generative cognition, right?
So for example, they inclusive.
This condition maintains
that no new elements can be introduced
in the course
of a particular sense derivation.
So what you want,
you're passing a particular sentence
on your deriving
a particular representation of that.
You aren't
just going to randomly introduce
a new lexical item or you know, just,
just for the sake of it,
you're only going to do it if it
contributes to immediate interpretation.
And so only existing elements
can be rearranged, restricting available
resources.
But it's also clear to what
extent this computational principle finds
analogous examples
in non-coercive domains.
So one way
of motivating these language specific
generalizations
by making direct reference to the debate
will not only foster.
I think that we'll create relationships
within that.
There is a kind of neurobiology
because those are both the explanatory
scope for the existence and prevalence
of particular syntactic phenomena.
And but what's interesting to note
is that linguists readily admit
to lacking a specific theory
of computational language.
Like I said at the beginning, it's kind
of a programmer is a programmatic notion.
So in a recent paper,
the way when Chomsky points out,
be sure we do not have a general theory
of computational efficiency,
but we do have some observations
that are pretty obvious and should be of
is basically the same field
that linguists are very well
a hundred theories of language specific
efficient efficiency criteria.
But translating that into kind of more
domain general goal areas.
This has not been so successful,
but we can at least suppose that
whatever definition will be forthcoming
will be related to more generic notions
of the economy, like Hamiltonian notions
or minimizing energy expenditure
during language processing.
A short description of the minimal
description that reducing complexity
and the degree of associated belief
are facing.
Again, like I said in a revised one,
if needed, I'm be
so one of these so-called
minimal computational procedures
is well-advised minimally.
So this is the principle that states
that given a particular configuration,
it's the
and why a local relation cannot connect X
and Y if C intervenes and Z fully matches
the specification
of X and Y in terms
of the regular features of his example.
So in other words, if X and Y attempt
to establish a syntactic relation,
if you go if you go back to the long
distance dependency thing I mentioned
and but some element intervenes
and provides,
I can also provide a superset
of the features, i.e.
access features plus some of the
features, this box or relation
that's sort of extremely abstract.
So I do apologize for,
but this is a more concrete example.
So in the sentence
you have a one which game
provides a subset of the features
and posted by how
which results in unacceptability, but
the equivalent does not obtain in two.
And so a relationship
between both copies of which game
can obtain licensing interpretation
on the strike through denotes
the originally made position
after after movement has taken place.
So it's originally merged down here
and then you move the structure
to the beginning of the sentence
and to formal question.
So question formation often involves
just moving all elements
in the middle of the sentence,
the beginning of more question.
And so if you say,
how do you wonder which game to play?
That sounds pretty radical.
But if you say Which game
do you wonder how to play?
Which has the same approximate
interpretation, that's okay.
And the reason why is because that's
how it's only a
Q feature, a question feature.
And as it searches down
the structure of encounters, which game,
which game bears a Q feature
because of which
but it also has another feature
that the game
and so therefore it can't reach its
final destination the final destination
being its originally alleged position
after play, which only has a Q feature.
On the other hand, if you move
which game to a book, do you want that
and you leave how in situ
then which game carries
these two features here?
It skips over
how because how it does does
not satisfy the full feature
specifications of which game.
Right.
So it needs to search for it
and then only when it searches
back and reaches to its original position
does it interpret it.
So this means what this means is
when you say which game
do you want the how to play,
you're interpreting
which game at the position of play
because you're not you don't have to have
a condition of wonder.
You're not asking,
which game do you wonder how you want?
You're asking which can be
what the how you play.
It's all about the question,
it's about the play.
And so this has been argued to emerge
directly from minimal search,
allowing this high level representation
a principle to make directly
from practice of official reputation.
This is one example where you have
a kind of rhetorically kind of gross
higher order principle linguistics
being reduced to a lower level,
a more simple kind of element.
So translating into minimal say,
which you cannot even consider,
as I just said, when you search
the structure for matching of features
and to the minimal stage procedure,
it would simply skip out
to find the original copy of which game
because it's searching in across
the whole structure.
So another example of economy can be
found in the principle of deputation,
which simply states
that there are no typical symbols
allowed up to linguistic interfaces.
So these indicators are assumed to be the
conceptual and sense for what this is.
So in other words,
the two things you can do
with a linguistic
structure is you can interpret it
or you can externalize it,
you can produce it, you can you can say
you can sign it, you can go into Braille
and so on, or you can simply pick it.
So this ensures that the system need
not compute.
Symbols are ultimately superfluous
to the goals of either interpretation
or externalization.
So for instance, in three,
this has an argument
that does not have a symbolic role,
so therefore it's unacceptable.
So you can imagine the sense
what gave Jessica a fine
or the semantic roles of this
agent as a patient.
And there's an actual thing about
the particular tool, but uninjured too.
So there's an additional kind of location
preposition that they with,
but it doesn't have a semantic role,
so it can't be interpreted.
And that sounds kind of trivial, right?
Like most people when you
when you given these examples,
they say, well, yeah,
obviously
that's kind of not very different.
But actually it's it's a pretty because
it demands
actually has to be explained somehow.
And so one of the operations
that's been involved in this
minimal
computational procedure is called image.
So the operation, which simply takes X
and Y and forms a set X, Y,
it just puts two things together.
And this constructs the binary
branching structures that I mentioned.
But merge itself
can also derive some core
separately properties
of linguistic relations,
such as membership, a dominate time off
and so on.
These different hierarchical relations
between nodes and a tree in a11
branch retrieving higher
or more deeply embedded, the other one
as well as the other relations C command.
We can put that aside and so in brief,
much of the complexity is a syntactic
relations and can be derived
from successive instances of this simple
merge computation,
reducing
complex physical to simple invisibles.
So for instance if you the example
I gave here with which game
and you can imagine that the set a, B, B
and then if you would take
the same element B
and you match it with the set again,
you get a B
and then you can delete the first
appearance of B and then you simply get
the linear order would be be a broken
the actual set being affected by this.
And this seems to be
what's happening here
where you have a B over here, which again
and then A the whole structure
and then B again being originally merged.
So all of these kind of superficially
complex linguistic phenomena
which on the surface seem
very complicated, know very elaborate,
they can all be boiled down
to a very simple operation,
which is just to take two
things and put them together
that was thinking about this.
Is that related problem like a junction,
do not involve modification
of the semantic content of the structure,
the adjunct.
So an adjunct is something like a, like
a prepositional object,
like in the path or to the beach.
And so for instance,
if you take a structure
like John and Mary talk in the path,
the fact that they talk in the path
doesn't change
the fact that they talk, right?
So the actual original interpretation,
the syntactic structure of the integrity
of the meaning of John and Mary talk
is not changed by adding an adjunct.
So you can add an adjunct in the path.
But it doesn't change
the fact that John Mayer so so again,
that sounds like a very trivial property.
It's obvious, right.
But again, it demands
explanation has to be a reason for
and the reason why is it
turns out that when you add an adjunct,
you simply can't you simply minimally
add it to the end.
You don't change the actual identity
of the phrase itself, that there's no
what's called labeling.
There's no labeling involved
in prepositional mate matching.
So you don't change
identity of the phrase.
So everybody who's been acquainted
with the principle of least effort
and its process theory is a reference.
So strictly speaking, the be basically
is a computational principle, right
the probabilistic beliefs.
It's concerned with objects, absolutely.
Namely external states
of a self-organizing system.
And in a similar way
that identity as a researcher is that.
So there is much more recent
theoretic linguistics
guided by programmatic concerns. Right?
Like I said, it's a program.
It's an ongoing kind of ideology.
On how linguists
develop theories of syntactic leaks that,
like I said, that process
theory is a little bit less clear, right?
How it's actually implemented?
It's slightly less clear than
what I would argue may become more clear
if it can be accommodated
within existing frameworks and knowledge
that it can bring with it.
To help solve the puzzle of how languages
are implemented in the brain.
So here's another example for you
routinely poems that run evaporate.
So in this instance,
routinely exclusively modifies evaporate.
So the word routinely goes
would evaporate.
That's how they reject it.
So it cannot modify rain,
even though this word it's closer in
terms of linear distance to routinely run
the rhyme comes 1 to 3 words
after evaporate comes one, two,
three, four in terms of linear distance.
So the more, the more many we remove.
And yet in terms of interpretation,
they go together.
And the reason is
and the matrix predicate
evaporate is closer in terms
of structural distance to retaining.
And the reason why is that
rhyme is embedded within the phrase
headed by poems.
So it has its on it exists on a different
hierarchical planet, if you like.
It's kind of lower
down in the hierarchy and evaporate. And
so it language computes
over structural distance
and not linear, just
so sensors are not simply beads
on a string and not linear objects
and they have to be linear
objects in terms of sensory
motor externalization,
because we live in the universe
we live in and we can't
we can't speak in parallel.
We can only speak in a linear
transition, although there is
some evidence that assigned languages
can communicate.
So to some degree in Peru, by using one
element with one hand and number of
so there's some evidence
of sign language, you might be able to
defy the laws of physics, but
it turns out that's probably exaggerated.
So it is still a form of winterization.
But just how cold in translation notes
the language prioritizes
the demands of the syntax, semantics
and debates over other subsystems
like Morpho phonology.
So while two structures
might exhibit different linear orders,
they may exhibit
the same underlying hierarchies.
So here's a really good example
in English and Basque, the direct
object dependencies are the opposite
to the interpretation of concept.
So John have read the book.
You have John
that actually delivered an object
and in Basque you have a different order.
You have John bendable,
then the verb and then the auxiliary,
and yet they mean the same thing.
They have the same interpretation, right?
So this suggests that
a kind of more fundamental operations
going on here,
namely syntax, encodes
the verb under an object
as an abstract phrase
which omits the subject.
So the words in the syntax
in English, on Basque,
you have the same underlying syntax
which is subject and then verb indirect
object being merged with the image,
that being the first.
And then you accommodate this object.
And then when you look in your eyes
that when you
communicate it in the darling
and you do in different ways
in English, you do it
one way, Ambassador, another way.
But the basic idea is the same.
You have the same
underlying interpretation
that also accounts for something
pretty obvious, namely
the fact that you can translate
one sentence into one whole language.
Right.
That's that's that's a fairly
obvious thing that you can do about which
and so therefore there has to be
some kind of commonality somehow.
But the commonalities
might be much more deeper down than that.
Most people appreciate.
So through the various stages of language
development as well,
it doesn't children don't typically
produce expressions that deviate
from general grammatical principles
pertaining to the structure.
Dependance of a rules, even when they
produce so-called mistakes.
So there's been a lot of research
on child language development.
So in other
words, when children do make mistakes,
they seem to make mistakes
which accord with the practical rules
of that language, which suggests
that sensitivity to structure
dependance forms a core part of language.
So corpus studies of infant language
exposure revealed that they are actually
very few diagrams of programs,
so statistical procedures can help.
But there seems to be more kind
of sensitivity to structure
dependance which seems necessary.
And as a recent paper
also reviews, human learners
prefer to induce hypotheses
that have a shorter description
and the logic with simplicity preferences
possibly being a governing
principle of systems
all in accord with what
the FP would would predict.
So simplicity based preferences
and a range of formal language models
to really think that the notion
of minimal description that
you might also
invoke
the principles of minimum redundancy.
So this is kind of
a really important idea that
that minimal computational efficiency
seems to be a really general
cognitive goal of the brain.
And there's a couple of recent papers,
one of them in Tex, I think
maybe you already this year
and I think was called
memory is a computational resource
which showed that across
a bunch of domains, human memory
in its various guises also exhibits
utterance, principles of efficiency.
So I think not very surprising
to where linguists come along and say,
you know, language also adheres
to principles of official computation.
So all of these ideas
seem to be out there at the moment
and everyone's kind of coming to more
or less the same conclusions.
But it's just using different language.
It's using different
background assumptions.
But the general idea, I think, is
kind of they all mesh well together.
So as I said,
linguistic computation
seems to be optimized for the generation
of interpretable structures
rather than for the generation
of maximally communicative
messages, possibilities, in other words.
And whenever there's a conflict
between principles
of computational efficiency
on the one hand
and principles of communicative clarity
on the other the former typically wins.
Now, this is not to say that
when we do communicate with each other,
as with by personal
data, it's not going efficiently.
When we do communicate with you, do it
in a way that's a separate question from
the language system is designed in a way
as to maximize that communication.
So the normal functioning of syntax
seems to lead to instances which reduce
reactive efficiency
and prioritize inference generation
so that so the goal of the language
system is to generate
particular inferences
and representations about the environment
in an efficient way.
So here's a pretty clear
example of this, right?
If you take the sentence,
you persuaded Saul to sell his car,
the individual
and the object can both be questioned
for questioning
the more deeply embedded object
in terms of the hierarchical structure
for the Speaker
to produce a more complex circumlocution
so you can say, who did you persuade
to sell what?
What you can't say?
What did you persuade him to sell, even
though they mean the same thing, right?
Same words, interpretation.
All that means is, you know,
what is the individual
and what's the object?
That's it.
Just.
Just tell me who
then who the individual is.
But you can only say it
if you constructed
in the most computationally efficient
way, i.e.
search for the first possible element
to question.
Right.
If you search for the more
deeply embedded object, can't do it.
And so the structures in 11 involve
the same words interpretations.
Yet the more competition, costly process
can't be complex.
So this is a pretty good example
and there's plenty of examples
like this about it in the paper,
but it involves plenty of examples
in which there is a clear conflict
between syntactic
priorities
of just generating a meaningful structure
and generating the possible structures
that would actually aid
communicative efficiency
and communicative flexibility.
That's not part of language.
So the example
show that the acceptability of sentences
can be impacted based on the extent
to which the construction makes sense.
It contributes to a novel non redundant
contribution
to one's mental models beliefs.
Again, this is really directly in accord
with what I would predict
rather than those specifics.
Again, reinforcing
the role of syntactic processing
in infancy generation provocation.
So the degraded acceptability in 12
be that by the way, the reason why
these are number 1213 is because
that's enumeration in the in the paper.
So the reason why 12 B seems degraded.
Well, eight
seems to stem from
the fact that the speakers are unlikely
to be ignorant of the relevant content.
It's kind of a pragmatic reason
the kimonos are the source,
and that sounds okay.
But Kim knows what I remember.
It sounds kind of weird, even though it's
a kind of a grammatical sentence.
It sounds
weird because you would never say
it does contribute
meaningfully to just revising or
contributing to one's mental models
or beliefs about the world.
So therefore the language system
doesn't like it, which again
brings in closer contact language design
with the epithet and also cases
which are 13 real
how even processes such as contraction
of sensitive to hierarchical structure
and can't be executed
over and over and any random web.
So you can say
source code of the chemists,
but you can't say source the likens.
And the reason is
because there's a visible phrase
back in between those two elements.
Other examples I wrote that
there are in 14 and 15 you can say,
what do you want to do and contract
and say what you want to do.
But if you say,
Who do you want to read the book
and you can't contract back to generate
if you want to read the book.
That sounds a bit weird,
but you certainly can counsel it
and if you saw that to me,
I would know what you mean.
I know Gateway is no problem,
but it sounds a bit more awkward.
Again, the idea is that this invisible
phrase view that commits, that starts
contraction and I can
appreciate
computation or at least structure.
Dependance,
I should say, is also exhibited in more
classical examples in the literature.
So if you say the mind is happy,
you can question that structure
by moving the engineering to the front
and saying, Is the mind happy?
And so you might be forced to conclude,
well, maybe the question you simply say
is the structure.
I'll take the first possible element,
but that turns out not to be sufficient.
So you can say the man who is
tall is happy, but you can't say is
the man who told is happy because who is
tall is again similar to problems.
That rhyme
routinely is embedded in the mind.
And this phrase is the question is happy,
which is higher up
the hierarchy and is essential.
So therefore you have to say,
is the man who is tall happy
because is is actually closer
to the element you're questioning
in terms of structural distance
than the is in his thought.
So again syntax cares about structure
what kind of thing and I'm not
linear proximity
and there
are also constraints on this as well.
And so you can say giant chicken
and bread for lunch
and and you can question the whole phrase
of chicken and bread and you can say
what the journey for lunch.
But if you want to efficiently question
one element, that's
why you already knew that giant chicken.
But you're not sure what else you can't
say what the Johnny Chicken Uncle lunch,
which there's no reason why
it can't do that. Right?
Why can't you say that?
If I thought
and you already know why a chicken.
You know, someone just told you rate
chicken. It's something else.
And what you can't say
what the giant chicken for lunch
is the whole syntax respects the
integrity of the phrase chicken and bread
is it's a has a phrasal identity that
syntax respects and you can't find it.
You can't just
by the
phrase boundary and only interrogate
while
other examples
really across phrase phrase
boundaries of conflict boundaries
not just within them.
So you can say Sam gave a guitar to me
and loaned a trumpet to you
and you can question both elements.
You can say,
what did some give to me along to you?
But you can't say what that sound
give to me alone, the trumpet to you,
even though again,
in terms of communicative efficiency,
that's a pretty simple structure
to generate.
You already know that he alone
the trumpet to you.
You want to figure out
what Sam gave to me right?
And again, these relations of hierarchy,
you can find them all over place.
So pronoun
reference is a pretty good example.
You can say Mary said
that he has a lot of talent, I'm afraid
if you go far, in which case the pronoun
he is being connected with Peter,
in which case you have
a permanent he coming before Peter,
you simply take my best phrase
and question it.
I'd say that it's no longer accessible.
You can't say he has walked out on Peter
should go far.
That sounds a bit strange.
He should refer to someone like John.
And the reason
why is because when you embed structure
in one, a large structure, it changes
the actual identity of the conduit
for the conduit that and headed by
that is a compromise phrase,
whereas the conduit is headed by
he and Peter are simply temporary
and other puzzles exist here as well.
So you can say John, you can say
John said he has part of his house,
in which case he goes with John.
But it sounds weird to say in
John's house he organized the meeting
and when he refers John again,
you can kind of pass it,
you can force it,
but it sounds a bit more awkward.
It's more natural for to refer to Peter.
If you say in John's house, you know
someone else that organized a meeting.
And the reason why is because code
reference via this phenomenal phrase,
one is but since syntax preserves
interpretation across movement.
So the original structure
that's generated is a John said
he's in John's house
he's organizing a meeting
and that's that's generated
from a more original structure
he organized meetings hilltops
in which case you have a he
coming before John
in the same kind of temporary structure
that I mentioned earlier.
So in other words, syntax
seems to win over linear precedents
and other kind of quick examples
like this, too.
So you can say I for the book
that Sarah always wanted to say,
I gave her the book that Sarah wanted.
But again, that sounds slightly strange,
changing the syntax
by adding the overview element.
Change the actual content of the magic
phrase itself,
which allows more easier reference.
So and stepping back a little bit, this,
this whole framework of like merging
of generating hierarchical structures
has been argued in the literature
to kind of boil down from a
domain general lower
level computational procedure.
So some people call it
the universal generative faculty,
which is just the ability
to construct hierarchical structures,
a map of the different interfaces.
So the idea is that
when we have our system of moral judgment
promotion,
which involves agents, patients
and so on, that's there requires
some kind of combinatorial apparatus
to generate those judgments.
Then with music is the nonsense
the seventies
that musical structures
have a kind of prior operation to the
and then also with numeracy with numbers.
You can imagine
that it's been hypothesized by Chomsky
that if you restrict this operation
image to a single element
and simply reapply,
you can kind of generate
the natural numbers, right?
So you can kind of from the outset
and then imagine it with itself
and imagine it with the object and so on.
And you can call it zero and course
the next one
one goes on for that too,
but gives them natural numbers.
But the general idea is that
you have an underlying
generative faculty,
an interface with different subsystems.
So in interfaces
but with sound system, you get music
when it interfaces with whatever morality
is, theory of mind structures
or just information for whatever
you get, moral judgments.
When it interfaces with the system
of quantification and numeracy,
you get the natural numbers and then what
it interfaces with the lexicon,
whatever that is.
Even more mysteriously, you get language,
which is actually what I'm saying
right here.
So huge amount of sound music.
And interestingly, only language
seems to attribute
to these merged elements
an independent identity.
So with quantification,
music and morality,
you simply involve
a generation of a chunk.
So kind of talking about tapping
what we call natural language,
you seem to get an additional operation,
you know, for some things you chunk them
and then you give it
an additional identity
or you give it a kind of at the end,
the sum is greater than the parts,
I guess, that way.
So what's anything is
that you can use that merge
structure to then call it again,
but we can treat it
as an independent object
independent of its constituent parts.
But you can't you don't really seem to be
able to do that in musical language.
Sorry, anonymous domains.
So is also a recent paper
by standing who argues that this capacity
to generate nested tree
structures is a human specific
kind of a species property.
Right.
And it gives a bunch of different
and more powerful instantiation of this.
But it was clear that you know,
only humans have language
along one side that you got.
I'm interested
in a unique level of complexity,
possibly due to this linguistic question.
So for instance, spheres are constructed
from a rock and a shop.
But it's not just a sphere, it's
not just a rock was a shape.
A sphere is a rock was a shot
with an additional obstruction,
the functional use of IT utility.
I'm going to come back to that
in a minute.
But that language seems to be uniquely
concerned with functional abstractions
like use not just for.
And then on top of that,
it seems that only humans have what
Chomsky has loosely called the science,
but more importantly, so only humans
or scientists, not surprisingly.
And we can do things
like painting a picture or knowledge
of this complex sentence generation
where you get some weird event echoes.
But then we posit that if A is true,
and then we would simply say, Well,
I'm actually right, so it should be.
And then of course, on top of that,
we have the example
I mentioned Theory of Mind Box.
If I recall,
and I know that you know that, you know,
so there's all these kinds of weird human
specific cognitive traits, all of which
can potentially maybe be boiled down to
or connected to some linguistic capacity.
So here's a good example
about the hangings.
And these are five different types
of sequence sequences
that you can generate only human
being seen capable of generating fittest.
Just as I've argued here
and in the paper, we generate
tree structures, not just randomly.
We don't just do it
because we feel like it.
We do it efficiently
and in the end for the explicit purpose
of active inference federation.
So transition and timing, chunking or no
knowledge, algebraic patterns.
These are all nonhuman capacities
to the bonobos, macaques, batons.
They all exhibit these forms of things.
It's only humans that can do
option number five.
The next iteration of business.
So again, this is this
idea that when you merge car factory,
you don't just manage to write, right?
Car factory,
you're actually create a noun phrase,
a structure
that's bigger than the two parts.
In a way the factory is not operates
and cars are not a phrase.
You need both of them
to create and operate.
And then you can use that
and operate as an independent unit and
with its own kind
of computational identity.
So this leads to a kind of a more
important question, I think,
which is what is language, right.
We're all human beings have language.
We all have very strong opinions
about what languages
and but consider the fact that geometry
was originally
the study of language
right back in back in the day.
And what developed
a sufficiently rich body of knowledge
to abstract away from original its
original object of inquiry and the part
that also from common sense intuition.
So our common sense intuitions about what
languages actually have no place inside
data for common sense notions of physics.
So at MIT, Professor Andrew Petrenko
recently conducted a Mechanical Turk
survey yesterday asking ordinary people
what they thought languages primary
function was, and now most of them said
communication in line with common sense.
And you use this
this data to create science.
The idea from
linguistics that language isn't
basically an instrument
for its primary purpose
is to contribute to conceptualization.
And what a physicist
obviously wouldn't conduct a
to survey randomly asking people
what they thought the nature of life is
a wouldn't concern themselves
with people's intuitions
about how parts of the way
and and so on that the language syntax
I think should be investigated
using the same standards
of scientific inquiry
as any other object in the organic world.
There's no reason why people's intuitions
about language should be needed, right?
In fact,
if that were the case, would just
there's
no need for linguistic department.
So let's just ask
what around the people on the street?
Let's that's what we do.
So on top of syntactic phrase generation
and we can also frame this
as contributing to policies
used for particular
strategy, minimizing actions, and
not just generating linguistic objects.
So the rapid and reflexive identification
of objects,
states and events in the next hour,
well, through simple linguistic means,
a new complex lexical interpretations,
but some of the most common non
non all the fancy word nouns
aiding in the successful generation
of internal models of the environment,
using a limited number of resources.
And so objects in the world
have to be identified
and they have to be identified matter
immediately.
Right.
In order to be successful in navigating
the world, you have to understand things
straightaway and rapidly identify things.
That's kind of obvious,
but at least it's not puzzle.
So for instance, complex forms of
what's called colostomy plus to me
just means aware, having multiple senses
and complex meals, which turns out to be
much more widespread than most people,
because
almost
half the ways radio hosts
and complex forms of almost
6% of complex forms of question,
we generate that we're way constructions
allow for more precise and exact
localization in conceptual space
than discrete symbols and gestures
with natural language syntax, allowing
the generation of a more accurate
unveiling of contextual.
So natural language
syntax allows us to more
accurately position
ourselves in conceptual state space.
Right?
Again, I gave the example of a second
blue box to the left.
Here's an example for you.
You can say
in the poorly written newspaper
that I held this morning
has been sued by the government.
That's a perfectly fine sentence,
but it's referring to three
different senses of a simple
we're like newspaper,
so a newspaper can simultaneously
be a piece of information,
it can be a physical object,
it can be an abstract organization.
And we can also call upon
all of the senses at once.
And yet notice that this sentence cannot
possibly refer to anything in the world.
There's
nothing this is not a kind of thing
that causes us to explore
something that's poorly written,
something that you hold.
So we're not going to be sued.
It's not a coherent entity.
And yet the language allows.
Simple question is with one single
lexical item to generate
a very rich range of perspectives
to interpret experience,
which is exactly what you would expect
from the activity framework.
And so it seems that can't possibly be
any object in the external world.
A complex question
square like newspaper can index a 1 to 1
mapping with the framework
we are developing here.
Next, what items could possibly
be seen as hypotheses about the structure
of likely co-occurring sensory input?
Right.
Well, hypotheses about ontological
and maybe logical relations
between objects and states in the world.
So in a where it is not simply something
that has a conceptual meaning,
where it's not simply response in a way,
it is basically a hypothesis about what
the world is, what we can interpret
experience to be at any given moment.
And we basically test the hypothesis.
So we use the word newspaper as a
hypothesis about what's going on inside.
And maybe it fails.
Maybe it succeeds.
It depends on the context.
It depends on the state of mind
and also depends on our interests
and our contents.
I'll give some more examples.
And second, just to illustrate that.
So a recent paper by Parker
sums up a held by the makers of the Times
2020 and a paper in Frontiers.
They note that
from the perspective of inference, things
only exist as a label or hypothesis
or inference about hidden state.
So the contention
that I'm kind of presenting here
is that forms of complex meaning derive
from natural language semantics.
But a core component of this labeling
mechanism and active inference.
So linguists
like to talk about lexical items,
well spoke, table walk and so on.
These are basically
just hypotheses composed from distinct
knowledge systems in the mind.
So our sense of geometry, our sense
of place, our sense of social relations,
which can elucidate
environmental regularities essential
to active inference.
So here's some more examples.
And again, I like to look at
the make us believe in both.
And let's take the notion of vagueness.
So I was once an infant,
but I'm
no longer an infant, but I'm still me.
But on the boundary between infancy
and childhood and child and adults
and there are legal terms for that, but
that's kind of a just arbitrary choice.
The actual concept of infancy
is an arbitrary boundary
rule.
Some philosophers do actually think
that there is a specific nanosecond
which transitions
you from infancy to child.
But no, I think that's sort of
like I think applying fixed
by notions like that to intentionally
an inherently vague notion like infancy.
It's kind of a paradox.
It's meaningless infancy, just infancy.
It's not meant to be a precise boundary
unless you're a legal scholar,
in which case you can find
legal, legal boundaries between things.
But that's kind of irrelevant to science.
So consider someone like infancy.
You also have things like pile theory.
Say there's a pile of sand
and you keep taking bits of sand off.
At what point
how many grains of sand are sufficient?
But to make a pile right?
That's got the Southeast paradox.
And the notion of the vague notion of
pile is great for active inference.
It's great for generating
rapid inferences and assessments.
Well, you know, it's dangerous
to interrogate that sufficiently.
The system becomes exposed,
the system's flaws become exposed once
you're actually subjected
to all that much scrutiny.
And then saying things like,
Am I can you go into a library on this,
let's say a thousand physical books,
but there's only 800
kind of actual abstract
books in the sense that, you know,
every library
has multiple copies of different books.
So the life will have ten copies of the
Bible, ten copies of the Koran and so on.
Let's say John goes into the library
and he reads every book in the library
and then leaves the library
up and all the books are rubbish.
So we just assess the science about it.
Now in that case
you can say John burned
every book in the library or John read
and then every book in the library,
in which case he banned more books
and he read right?
He actually banned a thousand books,
but he only reads 800 books.
So the phrase every book does
not pick out a fixed quantity.
There's nothing in the external world
that actually exhibits a 1 to 1 relation.
In terms of quantification,
it could be 800, it could be a thousand.
It depends on my perspective.
And that's the crucial thing
about even simple words
like, look, they generate these
very rich, poor little perspectives
that you can use to whatever experience
will have no necessary component to the
idea.
For example, in something like a city.
So you can say London burned down
and was rebuilt
50 miles at the Thames
and London can still be London,
even though it's physically
completely changed.
It's in a different location.
While the woman has a debt and so on.
London is a very complex place
in a sense that you can decompose
into organization, sense, location, sense
and population centers or government
institution and with a single word.
London
does not refer to anything in the world.
So in a wasteland
there's no such thing as London,
but just a kind of convenience.
It's a convenient abstraction
that we use to interpret experience.
And but there's nothing there's nothing
in the world where London refers to.
Right?
So here you can use the word London
to refer, but that's an action.
It's an act of human will to actively do
that and choose to do that.
There's a choice.
It's an action.
Again,
one of the code of active inference.
You can choose to voluntarily
and willfully refer
to one specific component
of your representation of a city
to refer to something
in the external world.
Well, that's a context by context case.
The idea that London invariably refers
to a particular
structure is just not not just not true.
So by
permitting a more refined,
accurate positioning in conceptual space,
natural language, syntax, AIDS
agents in the formation of policies
to navigate and make inferences
about the environment,
the cognition is an ongoing process
of dynamic interaction
between an organism and its environmental
niche.
Yet notions like event
are also not predefined external entities
but actively generated
and populate the body language system.
And so again,
events are not things in the world
and events are things
that the mind constructs
so that consider
also that simple lexical items
like setting up properties that go way
beyond the semantic complexity
of the atomic representations.
So you can say the large school
with windows
next to the river starts at Nottingham
and has a strict headmaster.
I want to remove students
so there's nothing in the aftermath
of the world that could possibly
be a location, an artifact event,
a social group
are surely not absolute,
not that that's not an ontology.
And also using these kinds of sentences,
surely it isn't committed to the belief
that there are such things.
The world.
It's a convenient abstraction,
it's a fiction.
It's basically
a fiction and useful fiction
that is used in the service of inference.
And this is a very good job.
It's very successful.
And the fact that it's so successful
is evidenced by the fact
that philosophers have only just begun
to really investigate this phenomenon,
this this phenomenon.
So explicit
and has taken centuries of inquiry.
It's actually realized
that some of our most basic common models
do not have reference the things
of the world that just convenient.
So taking up a sentence,
the average man is concerned about wage
cuts because he means before insurance
does language committed to the belief
that the world is made of things
like average men and wage cuts
and relations of concern.
That's not surely not something
that we're committed to at London
can be, as I said, limited.
We want to believe
it's the man down below.
We will ten miles up the river.
And so we've got London.
So these nested piece,
which as I mentioned earlier, are widely
considered to be abstract or even simple,
which exhibit considerable abstraction.
So in other words,
that the people I've written refers to
and Holmes focuses on nested structures.
And it is also worth pointing out,
but even simple words
themselves exhibit
a considerable degree of abstraction.
I'm perhaps just as relevant here
as with this invitation to consider
applied physicists in physics.
Right?
It's a kind of hypothetical,
complete scenario.
So what is it that a sighted person knows
that the blind physicist doesn't know
if this is not
certain
experiential content? Truly. Right.
So what it's like to see the color red
that's not part of
the blind is just knowledge.
So therefore physics
can only capture the causal skeleton
when at least conclude from this
that my experience of seeing the color
red simply is a property of the world,
but one that we can't provide
any naturalistic counsel.
And the reason I mention that is
because I think that may also be the case
for words like London.
The book is Abstractions
are considerably much more detailed,
much more intricate and much more complex
than we give them credit for that
our minds have managed to achieve
an analysis of the concept of number one.
And number theory is very rich,
very serious field in mathematics
about about number theory.
Well, there isn't
really much of an analog in linguistics.
So lexical semantics is nowhere near
as across, nowhere near as detailed
and nowhere near as sophisticated
as number theory and lexical semantics
is pretty much the meaning of water
is the set of all things that are water,
especially if you think of a semantic
textbook semantics.
Textbooks are pretty much just that.
The meaning of the meaning of
it is raining just means it's raining.
Right? That's it.
Just like a re description.
And so, in other words,
linguists are very far
from actually having
a serious naturalistic account
for even some of the most simplest words
and which, again, might
which might just simply be because of our
cognitive limitations. Right.
We want to construct these objects
and so one of the were kind of ways
to exhibit this,
which puts me is by looking
to the philosophy literature.
So in the philosophy of literature,
there's something called external wisdom,
which is the position I've just been
taken, which is the idea that, well, it's
going to be kind of a 1 to 1 reference
with things in the external world.
And there was a survey conducted
not too long ago
which showed that the majority
of philosophers are extremists.
They do believe, in fact, that the way to
Water River is to take trouble with it.
So consider this famous experiment,
which I think contributes
to our understanding of active inference
as shown in a few slides.
In some parallel universe,
it said that water is not effectual,
but rather that some of the substance
right actually.
So in the parallel universe
prior to the exact same as well
except water is not made up
for its X-Y-Z.
So the question is
can the inhabitants of this twin
use water to affect the substance?
So extend the same no extend to say that
the meaning of water can't be applied to
the substance. And
on the other hand, in contrary
in contrast to the extent
this is what's called
the infamous position
which says that one meaning of words
is simply a conceptual
because there's nothing in the
external world at least interpret it.
So the intent was to say, yes,
of course it is, it's just a concept.
And so the term water
seems to be polyphemus between
some kind of common function make sense
and a more concrete technical sense.
So you can imagine that a matter,
let's say one of the examples that Noam
Chomsky is given is imagine that there's
a tea factory, but kind of explodes
some of the tea leaves in the factory
into the local water system.
And so what comes out
sort of is chemically identical
to the tea
that they're making in the kitchen.
And yet one them
one of the substances is water
and one of the symbols of this tea,
even though they're chemically identical,
right?
Chemically the same thing.
And one of them is water
and one of them is tea.
And the reason
why is because it doesn't one of them
satisfies the functional based criteria
and the other one violated
that.
Indeed, you
can imagine under the parallel universe.
But then just
the other is what he goes on potentially
where doppelgangers of our scientists
discover that
when and what they've all been loosely
called the mud.
In fact, a deep uniform structure.
So if they occupy Earth on Earth
and there's no uniform
strips, there can be anything
of in this parallel universe
that all of their example
substances would actually exhibit
a uniform structure X, Y or Z.
And so the argument is
that they can use the concept to refer
to acceptable physical structures
and then ask for that.
Right?
They could specifically use the web
to just read X, Y or Z.
But does it follow from this
that the inhabitants of original Earth
could not travel to our universe
and use the word mode
to refer to our computer samples
if they became too old?
And I think the answer is no.
They extend this would say yes, right?
Next sentence would say, Well, the
meaning of simply refers to X, Y or Z.
And since we don't have X,
Y, or Z in our universe,
when these people jump in a black hole
and come to us,
when they talk of they have to be
speeding with something else,
but surely violates the actual
meaning of the term.
What its conceptual representations
matter is construction.
So the idea that the natural kind
of the use of what could not readily be
extended to a place of a sense
doesn't really seem to be well-supported
and it's just not a good description
of what language
actually is or what it is.
Language doesn't really care about what
it cares about, what does it, you know,
it doesn't care about the external world
as it actually is.
It's not.
That's what science tries
to science tries to achieve reference
within the language system
just cares about active inference
just goes about making sense of the world
that's it doesn't actually care
if Waters made a picture.
All right. That's not true.
So we can use simple words like water
more to access multiple concepts
and then use those concepts
in the same way to back the reference
if arbitrarily
goes with it, and shows
that using government statistics,
the US government statistics show Diet
Coke as a high percentage of H2O.
That stuff from my well, in fact,
I'm drinking a bottle of Dr.
Pepper.
I'm not sure it actually
has that information, but Dr.
Pepper has almost definitely agreed.
The content of H2O and stuff
from the well in your backyard
and in fact Diet Sprite inputs.
So that are even more like H2O.
And yet
they're not in water for reasons purely.
They were content purposes, right?
So I think a cup of tea is like 99.7
or 99.5%, thanks to what I mean,
it's called a go take, right?
It's not worth it.
It's tea.
So moving even further away from this,
consider that even scattered entities
going by water.
That's not what skylands these scallops.
These can be taken to be a single
physical object on the sun condition.
So imagine a picket fence with bricks
or a called mobile, right?
The latter is a thing called mobile.
It's called the thing or the collection
of leaves on a tree, is not it?
Unless, of course, these leaves a place
for the purposes of decoration
or art installation.
And so the reason seems to be
that the mobile is created
by an act of human will.
Again, function of oceans, of water here.
So here's the question
how are these humans
behaving notion of function and intention
coded into the lexicon, and how are they
covered as part of any kind of model
under active inference?
Three Tricky question and
indeed going
beyond this to Bertrand Russell
and Banks who claim to object to this
based on spatial temporal continuity.
But it also seems to be not sufficient
for the forelegs of a dog
can be seen as a single object
on the many conceivable contexts,
such as if they were cut
off, tied together and use a toaster.
But they could still be understood
by its use as part of it.
So after objects
do not bear causal relationships
and they're also not
spatial technically located.
So an object is usually understood
to be a concrete thing as the confusion
when somewhere denied special operations.
So an object is
an object if we deem it so.
And in addition, I think
it's important to note that a psycho
linguistic lens is needed to walk.
This talk of extended
was one in journalism.
They'll just talk about language
without actually
knowing anything about linguistics,
which is kind of like a philosopher,
a physicist, like a philosopher,
a philosopher of physics,
trying to do a physics
without knowing anything about physics.
It's kind of strange, right?
If you want to do philosophy
of the mystics, but in language
we should really know about it.
So here's one particular paradox
in the foster literature.
The following contrast
has been called a paradoxical problem.
So you can say Batman
fights more mobsters than Bruce Wayne.
And but we also know that Bruce Wayne
just is Batman, right?
So therefore, we should be able to save
Batman quite so much as the Obama.
Right.
But we can't say that
because the software
and the reason why is due to linguistics,
it's not for the philosophy.
So then that as a constraint
on discourse, interpretation of language
through which whenever there's two
referential expressions in the clause,
they're default as not identical.
And this feeds
into redundant computation, which again
feeds back to efficient computation,
and as such reference is operative.
So we have to into
the Obama is a problem.
So the sentence and B forces us to say it
for different reference,
even though we know
it's the same record. Right.
So this paradox in philosophy of language
is not due to mind world
relations, it's just due to linguistics.
It's just a psycho linguistic phenomena.
So it is it's pretty simple
and. Again, one of the problems here
is that a lot of these
quirks of language demand, interrogation,
and they're not immediately obvious.
The kind of language is very bit
of constructing an illusion,
but we kind of become susceptible
to that.
To think about the things we talk about
are really,
really existing in the world
and in fact, you know, languages.
I like to think it was kind of a fairy
tale.
Using language is kind of more akin
to constructing a fairytale
than it is science,
because we're just constructing concepts
and using the kind of lipstick
and science language game sets.
So here's
another example of Escher sentences.
There's a
famous staircase
painting of the endless staircases
go round and round and round
so the visual system doesn't care.
Rather
the visual system just sees what it sees.
If the world turns out to be a physically
impossible construct,
that's not relevant to the visual system.
We just see is what I would say is
and it's the same with language.
So language also has things
like analogous things like Wall
Escher sentences.
So if you say more people have intuition
than I have,
or in Michigan, in Minnesota,
more people found Mr.
Bush's ads negative candidate, Mr. Kerry.
That's actually a meaningless sentence.
It doesn't mean that more people
went to Russia than I have
is I mean, in a sense,
it kind of sounds like it makes sense,
but it's completely meaningless
because you're trying to compare
it fixed on a quantity.
But two, a simple binary. Yes. What?
Not right.
You've ever been to Russia, yes or no?
And a more people means
five or six people.
So it's it's syntactically legal
but semantically incoherent.
And the spelling of sentences like that,
where it's kind of a language
system is very good at that,
generating the illusion of meaning,
but generating the illusion
of obstruction when in fact,
if you interrogated, there's no reason.
And again, this feeds of the idea of a
fission computation of our generation.
You know, the language just doesn't
want to interrogate to me.
It just wants to generate an inference.
Why is this person trying to say
it also
generated also thesis value by reference.
So this sentence sounds meaningful,
but there's nothing in the external world
I can refer to,
so there's no real comparisons being made
between more people maybe being being.
So in conclusion,
it seems that any object is much more
than its material constitution
or its function.
We can also use its origin.
So Thomas Hobbes talked about reference.
His famous example was A River
can be maybe defined by its origin,
and I think that's divergent
and go into different parts
and then maybe converge again,
but also a sense of continuity.
So John likes the person who was that
person is defined
by a sense of continuous identity
and not physical constitution.
And so when a child watches a cartoon
of the handsome prince getting kissed,
it turns into a frog, and then
it turns into, you know, a human again.
Once you or whatever.
But there's a catch
and then something happens.
The child knows that same person, right?
The child watching the TV knows
that it's the same entity.
It's the same person
that the prince, being from a human.
And yet again,
that's not enough to do a reference.
There's nothing that could
coherently exist in that sense.
So all these reputations, it's fine.
And in addition,
we also have a kind of a fifth element.
So we kind of call this
linguistic biases, the shaping object.
So that pertains to one example.
There were lots of examples, but one
example, the marking of objects images.
So if you say John painted the house
brown,
this implies that he painted
the external surface brown me into it
because we seem to have a sense
of objects as being concave objects,
which seems a lot like scenes.
Events inside seem so exciting.
So we seem to have a kind
of visually sense of what our house is.
So if John and Mary almost stood
five meters
from the surface of the house, but Mary's
inside of the house and John's outside
it, John is in need of a house,
but Mary is not near the house.
Mary is inside the house,
even though they're both equidistant
the actual physical structure
of the house.
So the house is again a functional
it's not just a physical object,
it's also
a functional based interpretation.
And so, in other words,
at least these five components,
they all contribute up to inference.
They all contribute
to generating structures,
or at least these are proponents
of somehow coded language.
I consider that to be one
of the biggest mysteries of
how are
these things encoded in the lexicon
and how it is that how these networks
across the brain
interpreted and activated during language
comprehension.
That's extremely problematic issue
because like I said, when we talk
about schools being having masses
and being large and near the river
and etc.,
we're using pretty much
all of these concepts at once
and we're doing effortlessly.
And yet somehow how they're actually
implemented is kind of a mystery.
But there is interestingly precedence
in recent
print literature for this suggestion.
So in a recent paper perhaps argue
that if it be is most compatible
with an instrumentalist
theory of mental representations,
which representations are useful?
Fictions for explanatory goals,
which is exactly what
I've just been saying about linguistics.
And this is also compatible with
certain models in philosophy of language.
We have endless perspective,
which is about let's go
items having to want to direct reference
and external well.
But I basically useful fictions
the composites
of distinct representations of the rooms
that I use
for successful efficient interpretation
and ultimately survival.
Right.
And it's
also compatible
with families, models of blankets
which have been argued
to be the form of neo, continuing
to have much in the council permission
whereby the barriers of commissioner
about school emphasizing
the interactive,
constructive nature of higher cognition
and generating interpretable,
actionable concepts.
Again, the crucial concept of actionable
concept.
It's a useful concept.
There's something that you can use
in some meaningful way.
So the long storage of frequently
generated
lexical characters on the material rules
on the line that created the planet
and language comprehension,
all of this seems to allow speakers
to categorize novel sensory data
into a discrete set of object
or uneventful representations.
So there are a few events
that can actually be passed through the
simple, unique schemas provided by one,
which increases the likelihood
of speakers avoiding surprising states
the more efficiently and readily.
You can pass a particular situation
as an event then,
but at least the surprise minimization.
So another reason paper notes that
the active inference model of the brain
assumes an imperative
to find the most accurate estimation
of the sensory observations
that is minimally complex
which has been recruited involves
exploration of resiliency
and which seems to accord
with how the language system provides
the most computationally efficient format
for solving the problem
of mapping being linear sensory input,
so linear sentences
to hierarchical interpretations.
So from the perspective of
inference, individuals need to minimize
the effort involved in meaning making.
So we propose that there is increasing
evidence from theoretical linguistics
and natural language syntax
and that this structure exhibits design
principles in keeping with the theory.
Some of a recent paper by Kristin
Christian,
she proposes that the goals of speech
segmentation, the sampling data
in a way that requires
the most parsimonious degree of belief
operating in the third principle.
So we've basically extended
these claims with the
methodology.